foreign
so one of the early observations of
critical periods is that if a child is
born with bilateral cataracts okay and
then
you remove those cataracts and they can
see but if you wait and you don't remove
those cataracts until they're age six or
seven then even though the physical
impediment to vision is gone
the brain cannot adjust to the visual
inputs anymore and so the child remains
blind forever and that's because there
is a critical period for setting the you
know strength of the synapses for visual
inputs and once that critical period is
closed even though the primary
impediment or the primary injury has
been resolved the brain can't
it missed its opportunity to wire
properly for the visual environment so
they'll be blind forever so the idea
there is if you miss the window and the
child didn't have their cataracts
removed until they were seven or eight
years old and you paired cataract
removal surgery
with psychedelics then the idea would be
that re if you know psychedelics can
reopen visual critical periods then the
idea would be that you would be able to
restore Vision because you would be
pairing the primary Intervention which
is the cataract removal surgery with the
reopening of the critical period to give
the opportunity to learn from the visual
environment in the natural way and so
with autism it's the same idea we're
saying okay there's a genetic impairment
that causes autism which we think is
related to an imbalance at this one
specific receptor which we can correct
by targeting that receptor but if we
just do that alone after the social
critical period has closed then they
still remain socially blind if you will
because we missed that window so the
idea is if we could pair that mglore
therapy with a psychedelic then we could
restore the imbalance and
also restored the ability to learn from
the social environment so that they can
under those corrected conditions have a
shot at learning the ways of social
interaction the way they would have
during natural development